SéSébastien Bovet
etet Daniel Thibeault.
TrTrès content de terminer la
sesemaine en votre compagnie.
DeDe mardi de politique dans les
cocoulisses du pouvoir.
- - Vous l'avait travaillé
lolongtemps celle-là!
- - Non, c'est en vous voyant.
IlIl va falloir qu'on commence r
cece qui est l'élément le plus
rérécent, c'est tout frais. On
l'l'évoquait un peu plus tôt. Le
gogouvernement
TrTrudeau, une ordonnance
l'l'enjoignait d'indemniser les
fafamilles des enfants on.
- - L'image que le gouvernement
s's'acharne sur les enfants
auautochtones, ce n'est pas le
gegenre d'image que le
gogouvernement Trudeau veut
enenvoyer. On a tenté de négocir
avavec les intervenants
auautochtones autour des derniès
heheures pour tenter de trouver
unune façon, un terrain d'enten.
CeCe que le gouvernement n'aime
papas, c'est les menottes qu'on
lului a imposées avec des montas
fifixes. On voudrait avoir de la
flflexibilité. Ce que l'on
cocomprend, mes collègues de la
CBCBC échangeaient des notes, ce
quque je comprends, c'est que tt
lele monde semble s'être entendu
popour mettre les choses sur pae
jujusqu'en décembre.
OnOn a déposé la demande d'appel
paparce qu'il fallait le faire.
OnOn va poursuivre les
nénégociations. Il y a encore
popossibilité que ça se règle ss
quque ça aboutisse devant les
trtribunaux. Mais le gouvernemet
n'n'avait pas le choix, la date
bubutoir était maintenant.
IlIl fallait poser un geste.
On v va poursuivre les
nénégociations. On est d'accord
avavec l'idée de compenser
fifinancièrement. Il a dit en
popoint de presse aujourd'hui, e
ququ'on veut, c'est davantage de
flflexibilité pour pouvoir gérer
leles montants personnellement t
évéviter d'établir un précédenùu
c'c'est le tribunal des droits e
lala personne qui dicte exactemt
cece qui doit être mis sur la
tatable.
- - On le comprend quand Daniel
exexplique parce qu'il explique
bibien. À moins que je me tromp,
ilil n'y a pas de ministre qui t
vevenu expliquer la position du
CaCanada comme vous l'avez fait.
CÇa nécessite des explications.
LeLe message que ça envoie, c'et
quque le gouvernement du Canada
n'n'est pas prêt à dédommager ls
fafamilles des autochtones. Il
n'n'est pas prêt à dépenser les
mimilliards de dollars, pourtant
pependant la pandémie, il a sigé
bebeaucoup de chèques. La
memeilleure solution serait une
enentente négociée où tout le
momonde y trouverait son compte.
- - Juste pour préciser, il y an
popoint de presse de prévu. Ce
n'n'est pas arrivé encore. Ça
dedevrait être dans les prochais
miminutes. Le ministre des
rerelations couronne autochtones
vava être la pour expliquer le
popoint de vue du gouvernement.
SuSur Twitter, il vient de dire
ququ'on souhaite préciser sa et
popoursuivre les discussions avc
leles parties.
- - On suivra sa. C'est un dossr
popour lequel M. Trudeau doit
reredoubler de prudence étant
dodonnée ce qui est arrivé dans
leles dernières semaines. On
rérépète souvent à quel point ls
peperceptions comptent pour
bebeaucoup.
- - Dans le cas de M. Trudeau qi
veveut placer dans ce nouveau
mamandat toute la question de la
réréconciliation avec les autres
totonnes, c'est certain que ce i
sese passe en ce moment s'inscrt
enen faux avec cette volonté
d'd'avancer. Et ça sera perçu
cocomme ça dans certaines
cocommunautés autochtones. On
mamarche sur des oeufs. Il y aua
dedes explications tout à l'heu.
EtEt ne seront probablement pas
susuffisantes pour tous les
grgroupes autochtones.
- - Rien n'est simple dans ce
dodossier. On le comprend bien.n
susuivra de près ces négociatios
etet ce point de presse
inincessamment pour connaître ts
ceces détails. L'idée est de
rerevenir sur la semaine
popolitique. Le gros morceau a é
lala présentation du cabinet
TrTrudeau. Trop de semaine s'étt
écécoulé avant qu'on sache qui
alallait composer ce cabinet. A
lalancé avec un tour de table.
- - La nomination de Mélanie Joy
auaux affaires extérieures,
l'l'exclusion de Marc Garneau,
c'c'est un grand pas en avant pr
MéMélanie Joly. C'esest une mare
dede confiance de Justin Trudea.
CeCe que je retiens surtout, c't
StSteven Guilbeault à
l'l'environnement. À Québec, çaa
étété accueilli avec un petit
sosoupir de soulagement. On salt
lala nomination de Monsieur
GuGuilbault parce qu'on a
l'l'impression que le Québec a n
bobon bilan environnemental, doc
ilil n'y aura pas nécessairement
dede confrontation sur les
ququestions environnementales ac
StSteven Guilbeault. Mais surto,
onon aurait pas souhaité le voir
auaux infrastructures. Parce
ququ'aux infrastructures, c'est
lului qui aurait signé les chèqs
popour les projets
d'd'infrastructures comme le
trtroisième lien.
LeLe fait que ce ne soit pas
MoMonsieur Guilbault aux
ininfrastructures a provoqué un
pepetit soupir de soulagement.
- - Je suis d'accord avec
SéSébastien. Il y a une nominatn
dodont on a moins parlé cette
sesemaine et qu'il a été davante
àà Québec, c'est celle de Jean-
YvYves Duclos à la santé.
MoMonsieur Duclos aura le mandat
dede régler ou de gérer la fin e
lala pandémie, mais aussi de
s's'asseoir avec les provinces
popour parler financement. C'est
unune demande des provinces.
MoMonsieur Legault a dit à mains
rereprises qu'il ne voulait pase
coconditions attachées aux chèqs
ququi arriveraient d'Ottawa. Cee
sesemaine si vous avez écouté M.
TrTrudeau, il n'a pas parlé, il
n'n'a pas évoqué l'idée
d'd'abandonner les conditions. l
a a parlé des Québécois et des
bebesoins des Québécois. On
pepersiste et signe du côté
d'd'Ottawa, on va continuer à
alaller de l'avant avec des
coconditions vraisemblablement.t
c'c'est Monsieur Duclos qui va
dedevoir négocier ces transfert.
JeJe pense que ça se dirige
prprobablement vers une
coconfrontation entre Québec et
OtOttawa. Je sais que Monsieur
LeLegault mise beaucoup sur le
frfront commun qu'il a établi ac
dedes partenaires comme M. Fordn
OnOntario. À Ottawa, on n'est ps
coconvaincu que ce front commun
esest particulièrement solide.
- - François Legault a dit qu'il
apappelait régulièrement Ford.
PrProbablement qu'il parle de
hohockey, mais probablement que
MoMonsieur Legault a dit à
MoMonsieur Ford de ne pas le
llâcher. La stratégie qu'on
crcraint probablement à Québec,
c'c'est que le front commun tome
paparce que le fédéral ferait ds
enententes bilatérales et ferait
s's'écrouler ce front.
- - Dans bien des provinces, on
esest prêt à prendre l'argent si
c'c'est avec quelques condition.
IlIl y a fort à parier que le bc
dede province atlantique va
l'l'accepter sans trop rechigne,
mmême si ça veut dire d'envoyer
l'l'argent dans des secteurs
dédéfinis. Et je pense que
MoMonsieur Ford qui s'en va en
élélection au printemps prochai,
s's'il y a quelques millions de
dodollars qu'il pourrait utilis,
sisi ça vient des conditions, il
vava peut-être les accès.
- - On a hâte de voir les
dydynamiques vont s'installer
enentre les provinces. Sébastie,
vovous avez entrouvert la porte
susur un dossier qui pourrait
cacauser des frictions entre
QuQuébec et Ottawa,
l'l'environnement et Monsieur
GuGuilbault. C'est aussi un gros
momorceau. Le troisième lien n't
papas rien quand même.
- - Steven Guilbeault vient de
rerenvoyer la balle à François
LeLegault peut-être pour sa prie
dede position pendant la campage
élélectorale. Pour ceux qui se
dedemandaient si ça allait laisr
dedes traces que Monsieur Legaut
didise de voter conservateur, on
s's'y attendait. C'est un peu de
sasable dans l'engrenage pour le
prprojet de troisième lien. Le
fafait que le gouvernement fédél
veveuille faire son étude
enenvironnementale sur le
trtroisième lien, Monsieur Legat
didit que ces pas nécessaires.
EnEn principe, si les deux
ororganismes étudient la même
chchose, il devrait arriver aux
mmêmes conclusions. Imaginait si
lele fédéral arrive à la
coconclusion que ces mauvais et
quque le BAPE arrive à la
coconclusion que c'est bon pour
l'l'environnement, ça va être
cocompliqué. En termes
d'd'efficience de votre argent,e
n'n'est pas deux études pour le
prprix d'un. C'est une étude qui
dedevrait arriver... Notre arge,
onon peut se demander si ces un
bobon investissement d'avoir dex
ététudes. François Legault ne pt
papas se lever le matin et dire
quque le fédéral doit respectait
nonotre juridiction et notre
cocompétence dans la santé et se
lelever le matin Martin et dire
quque le fédéral ne peut pas
dédéfendre ses propres
jujuridictions, notamment
l'l'environnement. C'est une
jujuridiction partagée entre les
prprovinces et le fédéral. Donc
OtOttawa a le droit de faire sa
prpropre étude environnementale.
- - Le fédéral n'est pas obligée
lele faire, c'est l'option que
prprend le ministre de
l'l'environnement.
- - Il n'est pas tenu de le fai,
mamais il n'y a pas beaucoup de
feferveur à Ottawa pour le projt
dede troisième lien à Québec.
OnOn ne célébrait pas l'arrivéee
cece projet à Québec. C'est une
fafaçon de mettre à l'avant-plan
cecertain des réticences qu'on a
papar rapport à tout ça. La
ququestion environnementale pèse
bebeaucoup, c'est pourquoi
MoMonsieur Guilbault en parle.
L'L'autre élément à surveiller
avavec Monsieur Guilbault, c'est
lala réaction qu'il suscite dans
l'l'ouest du pays. En Alberta,
alaller jeter un oeil ou une de
jojournaux, on ne voyait pas
l'l'arrivée de Monsieur Guilbau.
EtEt Monsieur Wilkinson qui estn
anancien entrepreneur en énergie
veverte qui pilote le dossier ds
reressources naturelles. Ce n'et
papas de bon augure en Alberta.
D'D'autant plus que M. Trudeau
cecette semaine à modifier son
didiscours. Et l'envoi un messae
àà l'industrie pétrolière et
gagazière qu'on doit réduire et
plplafonner les émissions de gaà
efeffet de serre. On s'en va ves
unune approche un peu plus dureà
l'l'endroit de ces secteurs.
- - Traditionnellement, j'ai
apappelé ça les hyènes et les
gagagne. Il y avait un équilibre
enentre le ministre de
l'l'environnement et des
reressources naturelles. Alors e
llà, on envoie le message qu'ily
a a deux environnementalistes, a
pepenche beaucoup plus d'un côt.
- - On va retenir sa. Quoi qu'il
enen soit, il y a des acteurs cs
dadans ce dossier qui vont se
trtrouver au même endroit à
GlGlasgow en Écosse. Monsieur
LeLegault, M. Trudeau, Monsieur
GuGuilbault qui est en terrain
coconnu.
- - Monsieur Guilbault avec qui
j'j'ai eu l'occasion de discute,
ilil vient de prendre le
poportefeuille du ministère. Il
didit que les sous-ministre ont
vivite compris que j'avais pas l
mamaîtrisé l'ensemble du matéri.
IlIl était en mesure de partir
popour la COP avec tous les
éléléments dont il avait besoin.
EsEst essentiellement dire au
momonde que le Canada a les moys
dede ses ambitions.
AuAu Canada, on est prêt à aller
dede l'avant et à faire bouger s
chchoses. C'est une grosse
dédélégation canadienne. M.
TrTrudeau voyait être, Monsieur
WiWilkinson. On pourra défendre.
C'C'est sans compter la délégatn
dedes Québec.
- - Monsieur Legault joue gros,
esest-ce que c'est périlleux?
- - On a laissé entendre que
FrFrançois Legault n'a pas
l'l'impression que les chefs
d'd'État vont lui parler du
trtroisième lien. Mais il a
l'l'impression que les
jojournalistes vont lui parler u
trtroisième lien. Il s'en va un
pepeu comme un commis-voyageur -
babas, c'est-à-dire pour vendre
leles Québec comme patrie
élélectrique de l'Amérique du
NoNord, convaincre des gouvernes
etet des maires de ville notammt
auaux États-Unis d'acheter
l'l'électricité québécoise. Et e
ququ'on me dit, c'est qu'il n'et
papas gêné d du tout du bilan
ququébécois. Il dit que le Québc
etet premier en Amérique du Nord
dedevant des états américains
cocomme New York et Massachuset.
- - Vous surveillait quoi la
sesemaine prochaine?
- - La COP 26. Comment Monsieur
LeLegault va se débrouiller sur
cecette scène. Il a été invité à
paparticiper à un panel.
- - La COP 26 aussi. Les retombs
dudu G20. Ça a été la première
réréunion en présence et elle
dedepuis deux ans avec ses
cocollègues du G20. On verra ce
ququi va en ressortir. Et les
nénégociations dans le dossier s
enenfants autochtones. De
reresponsable du dossier ont
cocommencé le point de presse.
- - On va écouter ça
atattentivement.
- - On a eu l'occasion de
s's'asseoir avec le gouverneur
gégénéral de la banque du Canad,
onon a parlé d'inflation et
d'd'économie.
- - Je regarde Les coulisses du